alright so in this video I want to talk
about some
behind rate derivatives molecules that
are related to sugar is similar in
structure or come from sugars on that
are in some way or another related to
biochemistry specifically medical
biochemistry and clinical correlations
so we'll start off with sugar acids
first one here is ascorbic acid or
vitamin C it you can see that it's kind
of got the furanose form this five
membered ring here with that that oxygen
as a member of the ring so it is
carbohydrate derived and vitamin C is
important because it's required for the
hydrogenation of prolene and lysine
residues in collagen synthesis and that
contributes to the structural integrity
of collagen and a deficiency in vitamin
C result in scurvy and what is like the
some of the key symptoms include like
bleeding gums and bruising really easily
and things like that
okay another sugar acid is gluco uronic
acid looks very very similar in
structure to to glucose it's got the
hold down up down
except that carbon number six up there
number six right here is not a ch2oh
it's not an alcohol it's instead a
carboxylic acid okay so that actually
looks like this and of course it can be
written in its carboxylate form okay
gluco uronic acid it shows up in and end
is important in the structure of
glycosaminoglycans or gee-gees or gags
which are important in the extracellular
matrix and in connective tissues like
cartilage and whatnot google uronic acid
also reacts with bilirubin which is a
breakdown product of heme to form
conjugated bilirubin which is water
soluble and can be excreted safely
bilirubin is originally until until it
conjugates with Luke reader onic acid is
not water-soluble so Google you're on a
gas it allows it to be excreted safely
because Billy Ruben if it built up is
toxic
okay next up sugar alcohols are polyols
so spoil that a little bit more okay so
here we got goats are all very similar
in structure to glyceraldehyde which we
saw earlier instead of an aldehyde up
top here
just an alcohol and it can also be
represented like this where each vertex
represents a carbon and the hydrogen's
are implied and glycerol can the idea
here is that it can combine with three
fatty acids to make a triglyceride I
people talk about glycerol being a
backbone for triglycerides and I put
kind of here because it's not like he
doesn't just combine with you fatty
acids to make triglycerides at least not
in our bodies we have this in our liver
we have glycerol kinase which creates
clitoral three phosphate and that can go
through and to make foster today which
combines with the fatty acids to
actually make triglycerides but I
digress the point is that this is very
similar in structure to go through
aldehyde or dihydroxyacetone and it just
basically has just a bunch of alcohols
hence poly all's ok
sorbitol so sorbitol right here is very
similar in structure to glucose in fact
the only difference is right here it's
got an alcohol instead of an aldehyde in
fact we've got glucose down here most
oxidized carbon is this aldehyde right
here the difference between glucose and
sorbitol is right there so aldose
reductase activeness aldose which is
glucose here uses NADPH to actually
reduce glucose to sorbitol and then
sorbitol and this polyol pathway can be
reduced to two fructose by sorbitol
dehydrogenase which requires an ad plus
now sorbitol is automatically active and
it can draw water into cells and that
and in doing that it can cause damage to
those cells and this can be particularly
problematic if it builds up okay and and
it builds up in hyperglycemic States on
its life associated with diabetes so
hyper glycemia if there's a bunch of
glucose and a lot of it is turned into
sorbitol and sorbitol builds up and it
draws water in these cells it's
particularly problematic in cells the
lens and
and parasites in the retina and and
schwann cells so they can result in
cataracts retinopathy and peripheral
neuropathy in the peripheral nervous
system so so these are associated with
diabetes okay and yeah like I said it's
particularly problematic in those cells
because of aldose reductase going
through and is producing a bunch of
sorbitol and that sorbitol not being
converted into fructose galactose all
shown up here is it's basically the same
idea except and actually it's produced
from galactose though which is also an
aldose members of c4 epimer of glucose
so galactose is converted into Galacta
cell by that aldose reductase the same
enzyme is used here to produce galactus
all and if that builds up it can build
up in the lens associated with cataracts
in galactose chemicals in galactosemia
that is high concentration of galactose
okay so those are some sugar alcohols be
familiar with
you